bummed out about that uh iPhone
announcement I actually have a little
bit of tape from it I get really turned
on when there's a new iPhone and then
seemed to me from what I gathered the
camera is capable of making a major
motion picture but I just use the camera
for you know taking video of Beth
rescuing cats so I I don't really I
don't know I'm not going to go on a
movie set with my new camera movie
camera no here's the big announcement
and the dynamic Island looks fantastic
on the super retina xcr display oh yeah
they used a lot of big words like super
retina the knit here you'll hear and
then it's like the ab
cdfg yeah cuz she just said the AR of uh
something I was like what like gobbly G
Peak HDR brightness reaches 1,600 nits
so hdr photos and videos will look
better than ever the titanium encases a
new aluminum substructure that is bonded
using solid state diffusion he they glue
it together differently it's got
aluminum under it so I don't care and
it's bonded and while anodizing is
commonly used on titanium we chose to
use a PVD coating with Hardware
accelerated raate tracing a17 Pro can
run these Graphics smoothly great oh
robin look it's the woman from Apple who
made the announcement hi the new iPhone
15 has an a12 titanium Carbonite HDMI
LCD 5328 Ox bigir operating system you
will come in your pants when you see the
3,000 nit display the resolution is so
Crystal Clear it will melt your tiny
human mind and drive you to Madness
ma'am I'm going to buy the new iPhone
you don't have to sell me because I
always buy it and I always assume it's
going to be you know it's going to be
lifechanging but I went back in time and
murdered God Tim Cook is God now wow I
wonder how my dick di PS will look when
I send them to bed our new dickpic
technology is
incredible dickpic technology will give
the appearance of12 extra micrometers of
length and 05 nanom of girth hey I need
girth and length so thank you ma'am and
uh Apple can provide both this is the
Pinnacle of computing technology you
will never need another device ever
again until we build a new one in 6
months at which time your laptop will
self-destruct